[Music]
in you played yourself news played
yourself it submitted by summertime in
the LBC ooh a woman was arrested after
calling the police on her supposed
cheating husband she was a kid she was
arrested for falsely calling the police
the cops because your husband is
cheating but it's on mergency though
he's broke into my heart there's been a
robbery it was of our marriage he robbed
the last five years of my life he stole
the bowels away from me he violated it
there's been a crime sir yes so this
woman she suspected her husband was
cheating on her and so her name is Amber
she's 33 years old ah um and so this
happened in Alabama well they're saying
that she knew her husband who was having
an affair and so she planned to scare
him by calling the police reporting a
burglary at their home hoping that the
cops would bust in like while he's with
his mistress
oh that's [ __ ] up yeah so then you
can't use a cop
that's like swatting yeah yeah then
police arrived they found no signs of
burglary in the home and then that's
when they so when they arrived they
found the husband and the another woman
there's only one kind of Breaking and
Entering that was happening and it was
off her vagina
boom the wife come out in a [ __ ] pink
robe and curlers in her hair she's like
ha ha ha
she sure just called cheaters at that
point they could I show still around I
don't know but that show was a great you
know entering that person yeah so then
the cops said like they asked them if
there's anybody inside and they were
like we don't know but then they
discovered that it was the husband that
was there and then the officers once
they entered the home they detected an
odor of smells like sex Oh Lana so then
they discovered marijuana along with
cocaine and other drugs ruined across
like all throughout the heck
counter-intuitive it's party time
even was it planted even in the bedroom
of the Paris 5 year old child oh so then
not only had she made a false report to
the police that led to her being charged
with second degree possession of
marijuana and chemical endangerment of a
child see we need to have an
intervention because the real problem
here is the five-year-old doing drugs
well I I found this drug in the room kid
if I had teeth that bite you okay why
did you use these drugs and spread it
all over the house son I would blame it
on my kid immediately me my kid the user
and abuse so they don't catch him
cheating nope
waste cheating went away but she knows
about it so what is she trying to catch
sure did he know I guess I don't know
like impossible your hand did mine she
yeah she wanted to but she caught it but
there was another lady in there though
right
there's there was so does that mean all
that evidence that they found goes out
the window because it was like a false
entering no I wasn't why couldn't you
say that the other woman planted the
drugs everywhere but she invited them
into her house because she called it but
was her own house
yeah oh so she's going to jail because
of the drugs were in her own house yes
exactly that backfired and then police
were extra pissed at this situation
because there was a small fire burning
at a local school when she the cops
could have been attending Nevada instead
of this stupid [ __ ] off stupid this
person is though I bet you there's a lot
of dumb criminals like this there like
but I called you for the burglary though
not the drugs yep yeah I'm sure what are
the cops gonna do at a fire they should
be calling the freaking firemen yeah
[ __ ] out of the flames yeah it was
fire resistant she got cheated on yeah
cheated on there's other ways to do this
you can walk in and [ __ ] make up our
own viral video that's right now people
don't feel sorry for you I may be fast
I'm real still they won't say yep that's
it she's small she's like really I just
saw a video clip the other day of a girl
she was trying to record a cop who she
was accusing of being uh who's racially
profiling somebody but the cop was just
explaining to him how she I was like you
could record me that's perfectly fine
yeah that you can't get in the middle of
an arrest and she was like here's like
heels you're free to go she goes officer
am I being detained
he goes I just said you're free to go
did you still release that video [ __ ]
dumbass dude it's like what's wrong with
you people just want to be famous for
stupid [ __ ] now yeah cuz I'll I'm a
social justice where he goes you're free
to go but you just can't stop me from
doing my arrest so you could record
everything he goes well am I being
detained officer am I being detained
it's like that one chick that was
recording in an uber about the like guys
she asked him to take his hula dancing
doll off of the - OH
appropriation or whatever and then she
was started recording it and like posted
it being like everyone's gonna see how
ignorant you are and all those issues
the bully yeah you're being super mean I
don't understand that kind of stuff
because it's like it's you know like in
Hawaii that's like stuff that Hawaii
exports to all the - yeah they sell it
so how did that person wasn't even
Hawaiian yeah and how are you gonna get
mad about that's what their culture that
they export right yeah they sold it to
the tourists they chose to sell that to
tourists exactly they literally have
luaus that we spent a [ __ ] ton of money
yet like he's not painting a space brown
and being like oh yeah like what the
[ __ ] you say the person just crazy man
they aren't crazy they just want to
fight for no reason
so you know how I was wearing my
cortezes right and I had that post from
like Dennis as well like I never in a
million years thought that I would ever
be wearing critize it's just because of
what they represented back in the 90s
yeah
and then this Latina chick she writes in
the comics she was I don't understand
why there's so much negative connotation
behind this you know because brown
people are wearing it I'm like well it's
not because of brown people is because
it was gang-related yes you [ __ ]
[ __ ] exactly what I was saying it like
for good reason yeah you won't present
people in the now 90s people would look
in gangbang on your ass and be like boom
boom yeah yeah but she was just like oh
I don't know why there's this negative
connotation you know because brown
people are wearing it on my Android kind
of story where he was walking to a
liquor store and there's a bunch of
cholos outside and he was wearing
cortezes and he had his socks all that
rolled up hold up to him was like you'll
put your [ __ ] socks down you [ __ ]
[ __ ] because he wasn't allowed to what
Cortes and heavy socks even that's like
it was mind-blowing to me that I'm like
holy [ __ ] I can't believe I'm wearing
this cuz I grew up around that and I'm
like now it's just a fashion statement
I'm like that's cool but like a part of
my heart is still like well that's
because they didn't know the reasons
right
that's why they're making up their own
story and I think that's what happens is
people they they have to fill in the
blanks so they create their own stories
in their life what is it because I'm
Asian this and that and it's like a lot
of the times it's not history there's a
history that you don't understand and
yeah yeah you don't tell me what to do
with my socks home the minute I saw
cholos I already keeps my [ __ ] shoes
off and walk there barefoot minute I
thought I should beat myself up grab my
shirt like this why you [ __ ] beat
your own ass I'm your nephew yeah like
my neck works yeah yeah yeah I mean cuz
he's still kind of lives in a van look
like they were like were you from those
guys are [ __ ] that's messed up so
what are you from full I'm your neighbor
we grew up together man
yeah he's wearing like a MC I [ __ ] Oh
[ __ ] when they [ __ ] with people that
obviously look like they're not
affiliated they're just little [ __ ]
gays being oh they want to like boots up
there on you yeah yeah they specifically
look for targets that don't hit back oh
man it's just yeah so anyway so this
woman she is being held on a seventeen
thousand seven hundred dollar bond
remember the woman that called the cops
something damn that's a lot yeah and her
husband will also face charges for the
drugs found inside a home and the woman
who he was with will be charged for
lying to law enforcement ah Varys baby
I bet the wife's like at least she got
in trouble she's in trouble
baby come along I kind of missed online
culture when it was just kind of looked
upon as like oh you're nerdy yeah weird
because now that everyone's online now
you just see how [ __ ] up the world
really yeah it's true because back then
it was like well it was still kind of
weird yeah yeah and then if you met your
significant other online you were the
weirdo yeah but a lot of people that
went online were like a little bit
smarter and you know it's different it
was a different crowd now it's just like
the stupidest people but you know what
I'm gonna backtrack because it's some
good [ __ ] entertainment it really is
though
it's true when the trash when the trash
of the world gets online but then
there's some people with that CL is
trashed in the world they're like oh no
should I be angry too and then they
start getting angry even though they
they weren't originally angry that's the
only time I think it has it no you have
to go to Walmart anymore yeah I'm sure
that's true oh the world is Walmart now
that's I don't like following politics
anymore yeah I mean I can't touch it
like I've I see anything political Mike
those too many layers - all I know is
give me a thousand dollars a month
thank you I just know he has slanted
eyes I'm about for him that's right
black people voted for Obama yeah I like
to treat politics like it's WWE or a
soap opera right now it is like that's
so funny
it is redox mm-hmm I just don't want to
hear it
like that yeah
[Music]
[Music]